[Music]
welcome back to the special edition of
Hannity are Democrats failing Israel and
Jews in America well today we received
the sad news that 73-year-old godi hugi
became the first American to die in
Hamas captivity his wife is still being
held as a hostage there and earlier
today the UN Security Council voted to
increase Aid to Gaza demanding a
humanitarian pause the US abstained from
voting meanwhile so-called Pro Palestine
protests continue to arise across the
country including this one in Detroit
during a local Michigan Democrats
Christmas party this brawl sent at least
one attendee to the hospital leaving
others injured and get this according to
a new report former president Obama has
quietly lobbied in support of Harvard
president Claudine gay following
backlash over her controversial
testimony on anti-Semitism so this is a
lot to unpack here here with reaction
New York Post columnist and host of The
Carol Martz show Carol Martz and Fox
News contributor deroy Murdoch Carol let
me ask you first immediately out of this
is Israel situation you know we run the
risk of becoming inured to news about
Americans in Peril especially after
Afghanistan there was outrage
understandably over our 13 troops being
murdered in that environment but in all
of this discussion we believe this is
the first American to die in captivity
but we had like 30 Americans killed in
the the Hamas attack itself how do you
view this unfolding now as more and more
details come out and we have this
horrible
news it's so pathetic the White House
released a statement of condolences but
where is the outrage that an American
God hay has been killed where is the
American president to at least have some
harsh words for The Killers we're seen
is weak on the world stage because of
Joe Biden Americans being murdered
abroad cannot go without mention a lot
of people you know like to misunderstand
when a Jewish American like me says that
there needs to be a reaction I want to
be clear I do not want American boots on
the ground but how about some harsh
language how about a hard look anything
yeah see that's a great point I mean you
also this transcends whether you're
Jewish or not in fact though all of us
should be fed to identify as Jewish
because this is about a minority that
people think will be abandoned as it has
been in the past and so you this is
what's fascinating Dy we've got you know
again Americans you know over a dozen
now you know 30 who knows how many
really have been killed that we don't
know and will be and and yet it's like
the White House shrugs we've got ships
being attacked uh through the uh Iranian
proxy group houti they put out a video
earlier threatening America I I mean
where does this go I mean how much worse
can this
get it could get a lot worse I'm afraid
uh look people first of all let me
express my condolences to the family of
G Haan I'm sure this is very painful for
them and nobody involved in this deserve
to have what what's happened take place
but this could come here uh Hamas is not
just a problem for Israel as you said
it's a problem for Americans 30 who were
killed there about 14 who were held
hostage some are still held hostage uh
the Germans Dutch and and uh believe the
Danes just a couple weeks ago broke up a
Hamas plot to engage in terrorism in
Europe there people crossing the border
from all over the place God forbid that
Hamas decides hey let's uh go put some
pressure on The Americans on American
soil so this is not just an Israeli
problem this has already become an
American problem as October 7th and it
could become one if God forbid Hamas
decides to come and spread their
terrorism into this country yeah and
considering the open border years ago
the state department told us about how
Hezbollah
and Hamas were running some of the drug
cartel rings from South and Central
America up into this country you know
for the money I I mean it's so this is
we're you people have got to be ready
for for horrible news and we've got to
be prepared for it but I want do want to
move on to the nature of politics here
now that are happening Carol uh
regarding Obama and claing gay and
Harvard now Obama is a very influential
man obviously she has been I would argue
a failure it is as a feminist I was it
was wonderful to see three women heading
University speaking to Congress and then
they all failed right they all kind of
you know jumped in with the
establishment uh and for for women who
understand bias and uh uh unfairness and
uh you problems getting good jobs and
being treated equally you know we should
be on the side of everyone who has been
uh you know attacked uh or faces hate
crimes or distinctive bias why is Obama
you know spending some of his cache for
her well Obama lobbying for her isn't a
surprise I mean claudian gay is on the
team woke politics is a team sport and
she's on it I'm honestly glad that so
many of my Jewish liberal friends have
been realizing that their application
for the team has been denied please try
again next year look she's going to be
pushed out for her plagiarism and that's
fair I'd be fired for far less if I did
even close to what she did but I hope
she's remembered as the woman who argued
that calling for Jewish genocide on
campus had to be put in the proper
context her inhumanity towards Jews
should be her Legacy I I know it's going
to be the plagiarism that actually
forces her out but I want it to be that
yeah that's a very good point to I'm
going to give you the last word here
because there's a this is not just about
that woman or the situation with Harvard
this is a systemic problem especially
with the rise of
anti-Semitism it really is I mean look
if the question had been uh does it
violate the uh Speech code or the or the
regulations if you will at Harvard for
somebody to say hey let's have genocide
against blacks and wipe all all the
blacks out she would have said yes
that's awful we wouldn't permit that but
the question is well what about genocide
against the Jews well it depends put it
in context who really knows unbelievable
I mean that should have been a very easy
question for her and the other college
presidents to answer the fact that they
botched that uh show goes to show how
deep anti-Semitism has has uh has crept
into the left and this is uh one of the
reasons I think she ought to be booted
as well is 40 different examples of
plagiarism any any Harvard freshman
knows you don't do that she did it 40
times she ought to be booted yeah talk
about also a double standard with
Administration versus students and who
gets booted and who doesn't but also the
commitment maybe it's Obama's commitment
to Dei that this is a symbol of the
failure of that theory and perhaps they
just don't want the American people to
see that Carol Dy thank you very much
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else